Okay. It's actually time for us to finally start
trying to turn our ABO gene into an ABO
protein. And the first thing we're going to do is
go from DNA to RNA, which is the first
step of the central dogma via the process of
transcription. So if you look here. We have our
double stranded DNA, our double helix, and it's wound
up. We're going to follow along the gene right here,
and as you can see as it moves across, on
the, on the bottom region here we have the chemistry, the
chemical structure, and on the top region we have the
letters that actually make up the same DNA structure. Obviously, the
chemistry on the bottom is something that's a little more
difficult to read, and that's why we have the letters which
are right there on the top model. To help us better
see what's going on here in the double helix, we're actually
going to unwind it the way a cell normally would.
When a cell finds something interesting in DNA that it
wants to read more or know more about, it often
unwinds the DNA a bit so it has better access.
Now the cell is going to use proteins to detect where
transcription should begin. And we're going to learn more about how
that happens in the next lesson. But for now all
you should know is that this sequence region is called
a promoter. A region of DNA that's read or detected by proteins that signals the
start of transcription. And once the proteins are bound to the DNA And not only
begins to unwind but it begins to
separate into single strands to give greater access
and initiate transcription. Our double helix has
been unwound and separated into single strands here.
And for transcription to occur, it will rely on
a very basic property of DNA. So I want
you to see if you can tell me, what
property of DNA do you think is most essential
to make an RNA copy? Do you think it's,
that DNA is able to associate with histones? That
it can have a helical structure, the fact that
it base pairs, or the fact that it's inherited from
your parents. Go ahead and pick whcih answer you think is best.